frankie montas get ready to go again
seven shutout innings against the angels
on thursday ten strikeouts three walks
probably his best outing of the season
okay 100 is league average he's 15
percent better than that he strokes a
base hit into center field and then he
is a much better player over the last
two months yeah you know what i think he
had to get his strength up fam on second
one and two to manny machado first
inning just underway and he struck him
out tell you what that's a that's a good
repertoire we talk about yeah mixing it
up he pounded that fastball outside
cliff and then he drops that down low
that was absolutely filthy right there
it looks like a fastball on his hand and
falls off the tape very good contact
hitter in jake work wow waving at it
that's a big first inning for frankie
montauks and there's joe musgrove 28
years old 6'5 230 116 innings strikeout
percentage of 28 here's matt olson big
bat for the oakland aids
oh a big swing and a miss musgrove
strikes out olson full count now to
loriano two outs bottom of the first no
score padres and a's and there goes
connor swinging a miss
two strikeouts for joe musgrove montas
back to work a good
first inning good pitching in that first
hit the 3-2
it's that hard into left field
but mark
is there now here's trent grisham
oh waves at that struck him out
and threw him out wow he's out of it on
a big double play see lowry right there
108 weighted runs created plus lowry
playing well for the a's such an ace
thing as he launches this to right field
it is totally an ace thing and it's
beautiful i mean he had two years he
barely played for the mess comes back to
the ace immediately becomes a good
player again jumps on that on the inside
part of the plate you're talking about
joe musgrove when you go okay i'm gonna
sit on something and he throws the
middle in makes a mistake boom elvis
andrus
andrus lifts this to left fields
but collected by tommy pham one run
comes in for the oakland a's jed lowry
with the lead off home run we've played
two it's gonna bring up jake for
listening bottom of the order
strikes out tommy pham steps up top of
the order again we've got one out
carratini on second three and two with
tommy fam
he struck him out
strikeouts two outs here's adam frazier
two outs man on second
the 1-0
up the middle base hit karentini coming
around third and he's going to score on
the padres tied up good up the middle
hitting brian should be rewarded now
that's the reason you acquire adam
frazier good contact hitter drives in
the run with two outs i love that two
out rbis are the best in the game here's
manny machado
frankie montas gets out of it gave up a
run top of the order here's mark
markana puts this into center field it
stays up and grisham is there his
starling martay swung at the first pitch
first time up now he's 33 in october is
he playing like it
no no he grounds out jake cronin worth
ramon laureano now with two outs and on
first
and he struck him out so these
out of that fail to score a run got a
one-one ball game here for the padres
jake cronenworth eric hosmer and
jerickson profar
one two bounced over to first base
olson is there one out trent grisham two
on one out three and two to grisham
puts this in the air
center field long way to go and it's off
the wall marte couldn't get it one run
will score
loriano firing it in
second run coming in play to the plate
oh
and he is very out sean murphy applies
the tag on jerks and profile
padres take the lead but they can't get
that second run
victor carratini and he singles
into left field and the padres will get
that run after all
driving in grisham who's on second he
took second with the throw going to the
plate the padres quickly take a 3-1 lead
sean murphy draws a walk with two outs
brings up matt chapman he popped up in
the second inning to first base waving
at that on the 1-2 and joe musgrove out
of trouble again musgrove pitching well
joe musgrove cruising along here top of
the order mark khanna 3-1 though
and he missed it
i think that's what joe gets into a
little bit of trouble
1-1 now to martay
launch to right field not deep enough
jake mariznick is there and there's two
down it's going to bring up matt olson
big hitter for the a's
stroke to center field but again not
deep enough
easy pickings for trent chrisham
and the side is retired
[Applause]
jake cronenworth first pitch swinging
and into left field marcano with a nice
grab
catch probability now this just looks
like a nice little catch but kind of
goes a long way so the next question is
hey i wonder what the catch probability
is joe musgrove and frankie montas
cruising right now tying run at the
plate and chad lowry already with a home
run
wow big strikeout for musgrove gets
lower josh harrison steps up
[Applause]
but machado there's one
and they get the double play
andrew chapin comes in for the oakland
days again newly acquired
andrew chafin who's having a fine season
for the cubs
1.93
era
fields the bunt hunting for hit ryan
on top of the order tommy pham skies
this big major league pop-up
and that's three the seventh at the
oakland coliseum is trailing the padres
3-1 and here comes the padres bullpen
pierce johnson curveball specialist spin
meister
one generally in favor of getting guys
there's one
there's two and for johnson and the
padres that worked out he used merrell
petite
3.02 era and over the last five years
this guy's got a 2.78 era
hosmer
frustrated there lifts that into left
field
connor is there as the wind picks up one
out
and profile is frustrating cliff that's
a good sign when the batters are going
oh come on
that ball's hit hard
right it's short andrus makes the play
here's mark valancia in the era right
there of two and you see again the run
prevention is still there for malanson
full count
to l'oreal to lead things off
base hit got through on the third base
side
and down the line moriano stops at
second base and that man that got
through
so there's a lead off double here's jed
lowry
and he struck him out melanson pounded
that got it on the inside part of the
plate one out so harrison steps up next
first pitch hit hard gloved at first
nice play profile with a great play
keeps that and gets the out nice having
a short stop playing first base wow two
on two outs bottom of the ninth vo1
it's that hard in the hole cronenworth
eats it a run scores it's 3-2 so jan
gomes is going to pinch it for elvis
andrews the 1-2 from melanson
hit hard center field is dropping in
time run scores
a's have tied it up big comeback in the
ninth inning mark hannah steps up now
top of the order still two on still two
outs but now we got a tie ball game
connor lifts this in the air right side
uh-oh collision with adam frazier
frazier has that yeah
wow mariznick and frazier new guys
two new padres from just last week and i
thought marizna caught this wow frazier
took it out of his club
now we'll go to the top of the order and
tommy pham
fam swinging at the first pitch ground
ball oh
it short everyone scores for the padres
but we got first and third nobody out in
field comes in
on matt olson
matt olson launches this to right field
it's deep
they'll tie it up one run will score and
martay come in martay comes in there it
is and the ball game is over matt olson
has won the game for oakland down two in
the ninth they tie it up and they win it
with olson hitting one off the wall
that's a ninth walk-off win for oakland
second most in the majors but it was
deep enough martay would speed
five four a's